Mom, please call me back.
I think I'm dating my dad.
Oh, no, no, no.
No. Oh, God.
Dude.
Listen, I'm so sorry.
Me first, huh?
My name is Barney Stinson, and I am a
recovering serial womanizer.
We are likely speaking today because you are
a woman.
I once concocted an elaborate scheme to have
sex with.
I fully understand why you've exacted
revenge on me, and I apologize if I ever a
pretended to be a mannequin that came to
life and made you fall in love with me.
B hired a makeup team to transform me into a
time traveling old man and told you that the
only way to stop global warming was to sleep
with young me.
C told you I was Justin Hemsworth, the long
lost eldest.
Hemsworth brother.
Oh, my God. Stop talking.
Why do I have a feeling you have, like, 50
more creepy things on that list?
50. Like hundreds.
I did not crash into you to exact revenge.
We've never met. I'm just a new driver in
the middle of the worst night of my life.
I guess I would have recognized the three of
you if we had met.
What? You and your boobs.
What happened? My STD shock therapy device.
It's this experimental new electroshock
treatment for guys like me.
This sucker is programmed with 10,000
problematic words and phrases.
If I utter one of them, it blasts me with
enough electricity to power Staten Island.
Whoa.
And that really works.
Yeah. When I first saw you, I wanted to say
you rear ended me.
So how about I rear end you?
I. But I didn't.
Well, fun chat.
What do you say I Venmo you for the damage?
What do you think's fair? Like 30, 40 bucks?
Okay. 50. Final offer.
Honey, my left shoelace cost $50.
This is a new low.
First, I find out I'm dating my maybe dad.
And now I'm going to go bankrupt because I
crashed into the fanciest perv in New York.
I'm sorry. You just found out you're maybe
dating your.
Maybe. What? Who? What?
It's a long story.
How about you tell me your twisted tale of
daughter, daddy lust and intrigue.
And if your story is juicy enough, the car
is on me.
Really?
That's a pretty weird challenge.
If there's one thing you should know about
me, it's that I love a weird challenge.
Okay, so my friend and I, we went to this
party, okay?
And I met a chef.
Yeah, you did?
Come on.